[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeudi m
il ya une grosse clim sur le plateau je
les sens qui commence à megève et
bienvenue à tous pas mort elles sont
voilées ou aller où aller où elle est où
la moue la gamme l'amour la grosse boule
à la mauvaise blague
oula
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je du mend heures je vous dis benders
jeunesse bender tube the wonder woman
je suis dit qu'après vous mais j'ai
tombé
je suis tombé
m pokora je la kiffe ça j'ai écouté ce
matin mais fataliste que j'écoutais et
donc il connaît mon épouse et tu pas
qu'avec moi ça marche pas comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
jo
g
c'était
enfin
[Applaudissements]
merci
après le grand patron le grand patron de
canal algérie
dis moi tu sais où elle est où elle est
où gérald
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors qu'ils n'ont d'égal à égal au chat
live à li na waie et emmanuel rolland
si j'avais l'impression c'est quand tu
comptais parents à la maison mais c'est
un truc de ouf avait la recherche
il manque une fiche
[Musique]
non mais quelle information là dedans
arrêté qui va faire ça vous allez dire à
votre mère chère maman regarde je sais
comment pirater une lettre dit pas de
bêtise et oui alors moi je mais c'est
vrai qu'en même temps mais on reste sur
le débat là le constat est rude tâche
mode d'emploi en revanche tu parles du
côté écologique de la belette rodin mais
en sortant de ma vie
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la moule à la poule à jack roulette à
bogota à chaque fois vous intervenez il
me regarde et me il est complètement fou
[Musique]